et le bilan de la frappe attribue à la
Russie samedi contre cet immeuble
d'habitation et donc maintenant de 45
civils tués dont 6 enfants on en parle
avec notre correspondant à Kiev bonjour
Gulliver crag l'Ukraine dénonce toujours
un des bombardements les plus meurtriers
sur un site civil depuis le début de
l'invasion russe
oui
au moins souvenir il y a pas eu de
attaque plus meurtrier sur un seul
immeuble en Ukraine loin de la ligne de
front depuis le début de l'invasion en
février dernier et il y a encore une
vingtaine de personnes qui sont portées
disparus mais les services secours ont
arrêté leurs opérations du fait que
trois nuits en température bien en
dessous de zéro il est très peu probable
que quiconque est plus survivre de la
vie de Boris Filatov qui cite les
experts qui lui ont informé Boris Pilate
of Lemaire de ni pro il est possible que
certaines de ces personnes étaient tout
simplement entièrement consommé par les
flammes et c'est pour cela qu'il n'a pas
été possible de trouver leur corps
certains des cours des victimes qui ont
été trouvés étaient apparemment
seulement une partie des parties de leur
corps qui ont été trouvés ils restaient
entièrement brûlé alors c'est vraiment
une attaque
qui a secoué l'Ukraine même plus que
d'autres attaques et d'autres événements
récents c'est quelque chose qui a
provoqué une très grande colère et
augmenter si c'était possible encore la
détermination je pense des Ukrainiens à
obtenir les armes dont ils ont besoin de
leur partenaire occidentaux pour enfin
revenir renouveler leur contre-offensive
contre la Russie précisément bonjour
qui sous quelle forme il a eu cette
rencontre la première entre le
commandant en chef de l'armée
ukrainienne et le chef d'état-major
américain
oui je pense que cela en dit long sur
l'importance de la rencontre si Valère
isaluchni à fait l'effort et c'est la
première fois qu'il sort de l'Ukraine
depuis le début de l'invasion de faire
ce voyage au moins 7h de route pour
rencontrer ce homologue américain en
Pologne les États-Unis bien sûr sont le
plus grand fournisseur d'armes à
l'Ukraine de loin ils ont dépensé plus
de 18 milliards de dollars aux normes
seulement pour l'Ukraine derrière eux
c'est en fait l'Allemagne qui arrive en
deuxième position avec un peu plus de 4
milliards de dollars dépensés ce qui
peut surprendre vu que l'Allemagne est
toujours très critiqué pour sa réticence
à prendre les décisions elle prend les
décisions lentement avant de fournir les
armes demander par l'Ukraine et c'est
vraiment l'Allemagne qui qui sur sur
laquelle il y a toute la tension cette
semaine c'est en Allemagne que se
tiendra vendredi la rencontre des
ministres de défense de l'OTAN sur la
base aérienne de Rammstein et c'est
l'Allemagne qui doit donner sa réponse
oui ou non est-ce qu'elle va permettre
aux pays tiers notamment la Pologne et
la Finlande de livrer à l'Ukraine des
chars de type léopard 2 et est-ce
qu'elle va elle-même livrer ses chars
c'est une des réponses clés qui est
attendue à Rammstein mais il n'est pas
en fait claire combien de Séchard il y a
dans les pays de l'Union européenne
membres aussi de l'OTAN qui sont en
réalité en état de marche certains
voient s'élèvent pour dire que on parle
des centaines de sécheurs qui seraient
disponibles mais en fait ils ne sont
peut-être pas si disponibles que cela
parce que il nécessiterait des mois
d'entretien avant de pouvoir être remise
en service et en voyant Ukraine que
l'hiver crack depuis Kiev pour Paris
direct merci beaucoup Gul